hello everybody hope that you are good
different kind of video today it's not
going to be that much about Bitcoin and
they trading no it's going to be more
about altcoins as specifically
artificial intelligence altcoins and um
you could take this as a swing trading
idea or investing opportunity of course
nothing here is financial advice I'm
just talking about what I think my
opinion and why artificial intelligence
well I think it's pretty simple it's
literally the strongest Narrative of
this bull market and you can see what
this is doing the S SMP is going up and
broke the highs because there is one
asset that it's Nvidia that have
outperformed the whole Market even has
outperformed Bitcoin since the start of
a year let's check it out go to the NV
media chart on the NASDAQ daily time
frame all right and if you
notice since January 1 is around here
yep it's going
up % up that's a times two Bitcoin has
gone up 70% so yes Nvidia has out
performed Bitcoin and this pump is
basically because artificial
intelligence and also last week we had
the Nvidia conference and in that
conference they mainly talked about what
new Chips but also artificial
intelligence and you can see that what
Nvidia has done since that day Tuesday
19 is going
up another 15% how does this affect
artificial intelligence tokens of crypto
obviously in the same way I have here
um um a tech list I don't know how you
call it but I basically track this list
this coins okay today I'm going to show
you the one of crypto artificial
intelligence of course there also like
gaming and Louch pands which are the
three narratives that I'm putting my
money on for this bull market but the
artificial intelligence is obviously
going to be the strongest one now if you
notice here we've had some nice
pullbacks okay we're going to talk about
fats oan pal delium render there are
many coins here to talk about I'm going
to try to keep this video nice and short
but most likely it's going to be a bit
longer so get yourself a coffee and
let's talk about this so what is fetch
most of you know fetch is an artificial
int intelligence uh project that is
focused on artificial intelligence
agents okay now ocean however is an
artificial intelligent design that is
more focused on processing data and
analytics so you can see how these two
can link you know you have Fetch with an
artificial intelligence model that is
generating data and then ocean for
example if they partner think they have
a partnership ocean can help to process
all that data okay and organize it so
they can see how artificial intelligence
can work together between the projects
and I think this was uh this is a
current example these two are partnering
together but then you see for example
have and other two that I've selected
pal and theim this two are quite similar
because both of them are more focused in
assistance of crypto so for example P
you can get both um you can put a telam
channel well a telegram group chat to
help to answer questions but the
leum has something in their website in
their platform that's called Lucy Lucy's
um artificial
intelligence some kind of assistance
that it can help you to answer your
questions about crypto uh it can buy
tokens for you you can tell Lucy okay
get to my metamask wallet and there are
$10 there buy ethereum okay in Unis Swap
and they'll do it so these two are kind
of assistance and I mean if you look at
the chart you can see how they've been
going up nonstop okay this is pal and
this is delium pretty similar charts if
you Noti okay now there is one reason
why I like delium more and it well there
are a couple of reasons one of the
reasons is because delium also has a
decentralized structure for game
publishing um that's very big because
it's going to help also to the other big
narrative that I support that is crypto
gaming it's going to help to publish
games okay so uh to me that's huge and
that's something that I really like and
it's something extra and the other
reason why I like it more than than pal
and don't misunderstand me pal is also a
great project but theum offers very good
rewards for staking okay they also have
notes we're going to talk about these
rewards and these notes later we're
going to go into their website we're
going to have a look because it's
something quite interesting okay then
you have render well everybody knows
what what render is doing uh huge huge
perform look at that insane perform all
right and then here there is a few other
tokens like Dex check type chain GPT and
self key these last four um I'm not
particularly sure about them yet so I
don't want to talk much about them I
included change jpt because um I get uh
free tokens from aak in cify cify it's a
Louch pad where chpt was released and
because they work together I get air
drop some tokens every day but I'm not
want to talk about investing in chpt I'm
just happy because I'm receiving some
tokens so I like to see what price is
doing then we have um self key H it
doesn't have I think much market cap so
not sure about this yet I'm still having
a look not I'm not interested in
investing so far still doing my research
same goes for type it's uh it's doing
amazing performance and I just want to
also try to understand what is is doing
I don't have much idea and then we have
Dex check Dex check uh has dropped more
than more than the rest if you notice
now it's at the at the at the daily 50
Ma so it's a good buying Zone but I'm
not buying uh because I'm not not
convinced about the project just yet
okay it's kind of like a dashboard that
helps you to do some analytics of tokens
and of chains and what projects are
working or getting developed in what
chains but not sure yet also they say
that they are working in in their own
Louch pad I want to see how the lunch
pad goes but not convinced yet to put my
money on here okay so for now I would
say that the best tokens are this ones
here that you can see in red fets oan
pal delium and render now the problem is
that the price is going quite high and I
talk this about about this in the
telegram channel on suay I bought some
of these tokens because I thought the
price you know it dropped 25 30% so okay
that's a good pullback I can join in and
up of some feds I bought a lot of
oan um the O I bought a lot of 106 so
around here okay and today I'm planning
to buy delici and I'm going to show you
why so what I see in these tokens is
that fetch is the strongest one is the
one that gains the momentum the fastest
so when there is a deep the first going
that is going to outperform the rest is
fetch it goes up stra away and then
ocean and render there a bit uh delay
behind um they tend to pump after fetch
do you can see their charts are quite
similar but then there are two coins
that move pretty much the same and those
are PAL and delici and you can see here
in the four time frame that pal managed
to push above the 50 ma in the four time
frame drop little retrace to test it as
support and ination okay now if you look
at the lium what lium is doing is pretty
much the same it's a bit delayed from
pal okay push up retrace continuation
and if I use my indicator I can see that
there is a week at 057 okay and from the
4 or 50 May that is pretty much a 25%
pump so that's why I think that as the
market is right now uh the ideal thing
was to obviously load on the on fet
Ocean render at the weekend well to be
honest render still hasn't done anything
so pretty much Fetch and ocean and now
in my opinion the best place to follow
uh pal through the lium so if pal has
moved like this most likely think is
that the leion moves like this plus we
are also going to talk now about the
rewards that they are offering and also
very important never put all the eggs in
one basket and that means to not go all
in and to not stay out fully okay so the
way that I'm playing this is as I said
on Sund I got some tokens of oan so for
example in Ocean I go some at 106 and
what I'm planning is okay I bought some
here and I've have also left some orders
lower in case I'm wrong and Bitcoin goes
lower okay if Bitcoin has a retrace and
doesn't go to 78k and instead it goes to
62k which I don't see that happening I
think that it's more likely that goes up
but if he if I'm wrong goes down then
I'm leaving some orders lower for o so
for example this area here okay in this
area here we have support you can see
here support support and also the daily
508 so I bought some at 106 and I left
some orders at 095 okay so that's the
way I'm playing this go to the elisium
doing the same I'm buying some today but
I'm also going to buy some low okay so
if price drops I'm planning to buy here
also okay that's a
c33 previous resistance that should be
now Support also matching with the daily
50 ma all right so DCA in and DCA out
that's the strategy that is the safest
this is their website and don't get me
wrong this is not a random coin it's
this this coin has 300 million market
cap it's huge okay and they're working a
lot of things I mean I haven't seen this
last week okay artificial intelligence t
um I have to do some research about this
because I haven't seen what it is but I
see that you can apply for it so it's
something real something tangible and
it's not smoke okay it's actually
something you can actually use same go
for Lucy Lucy is here um you can see
here has some examples what tokens do
balik own it tells you what his wallet
is transfer tokens to another wallet it
can do it for you so it can help you to
manage your portfolio convert $10 in my
wallet to ethereum on uniso you mean if
you basically give him access and it
helps you to manage your portfolio so
this is probably something that I'll use
in the future when it's uh not in Early
Access but it's fully released so for
now I'm interested I want to see uh how
this gets into into the public fully
finished um then I'll probably uh going
to see what the previous users say about
it if they like it or not and maybe try
it give it a try but to me the most
interesting thing about elium is this
the dmas these are their notes notes in
crypto are a great way to earn passive
income and I'm going to show you a real
example okay because I played with this
a bit yesterday I about one note now
these notes are very interesting because
they are very limited okay the total
Supply I think is 50,000 and they
already sold a third of them they've
sold
16,000 now I think it's better every 100
notes the price increases $25 so you can
see that they get more limited and more
limited and more limited now for example
let's say the price y they bought at
2,600 now has
2,625 okay so they've sold at least 100
notes since yesterday and yeah tot
Supply 50,000 so just with one note I
want to show you what I did since
yesterday in one day okay let's go to
the dma rewards that's my
dashboard
and I've already made
tokens well let me show you okay
yesterday I sted only
$502 tokens because I wanted to try I
just wanted to try how they know was and
I wanted to see that if I just take 100
tokens a around number how much it could
get back okay and in only one day you
can click here my positions you see here
102 tokens this is the APR I get a boost
for the note now of course the more
notes you have the more multiplier so
imagine if you have two or three or five
notes is crazy loyalty boost uh not sure
what this is but more boosts and this
unlocks in 28 days okay well there's
more say 29 days maybe because he just
done the change to the 48 hours but the
rewards that I've received so far are
only for one day
I think I get the rewards in the night
time but anyway in one day by staking
$50 102 tokens I've already
got 18 tokens that's around $9 $890 $890
$9 with only an investment of $50 St
plus one note now of course I look at
this and I'm thinking that I should a
stake today more maybe should take today
$500 or $1,000 or buy a second note so
of course I'm going to go more into this
um this is what I like the most about
the project because the leim is of
course going to follow the artificial
intelligence narrative and it's the
token that I giv the most rewards in the
long term not only for the fluctuation
of price difference that of course is
going to give you money because
artificial intelligence is here to stay
and the narrative is very strong all the
artificial intelligence tokens are going
to keep going up these guys you can go
to their Twitter they do EMAs pretty
much every day they are very engaged
with the community the project is here
to stay he's been here for many years
300 million Market Market capup is
surviv the bare
market so all of that is going to make
the price of the token to continue going
up like the rest of artificial
intelligence tokens but not only that
I'm going to be able to make a lot of
money in passive income through their
notes and is taken so this is what I
mean literally what this is telling me
is that in six days in six days with
only one
note and only taking looking up for one
month because uh imagine that I don't
know something changes in the market and
I want to sell what I what I stake I
can't but in 30 days I will be able to
it's not the same to stake for one month
than to stake for a year of course I
have a lot less risk if I stake for one
month so staking for one month which is
very good I can get my investment back
in 6 days with only one note so this is
huge okay so I would recommend you to
have a look at all the projects that I
said also going to go to coin market cap
or Co Geo go to the artificial
intelligence category and you're going
to see a lot more projects these are my
favorite ones delium is my top one
artificial intelligence coins because
the long-term rewards that is
given and also there is a referral code
here that I'll leave in the description
but you can you can copy and paste that
it's also going to give you more rewards
when you stake so you're going to have
my well this rewards here this
multipliers plus also you're going to
get more by using the referral code or
if you have a friend that has at least
one note okay because you get the
referral code once that you own at least
one note so if you have a friend owns a
note you can also use the referral code
but use a referral code if you want to
do this because you're going to get more
rewards so it could be as shame not to
so that's pretty much everything guys
artificial intelligence
altcoin checklist done so thank you so
much for watching guys and I'll see you
soon